ah [ __ ] you hello welcome back to me
plague do better at this game called
wick and I am going to be out of candles
very soon oh ah look what my little
niece made for me Oh stay away from her
but why she looks so friendly oh I want
to give her a big hug on her little
spindly arms and weird head looks like
she killed a skunk and draped it across
her hair oh so delicately oh she's
adorable that's now the whispering oh
the comforting whispering of my home
here in the woods oh I can't wait to go
back to my homestead here in the middle
of nowhere and die once again I would
like to reiterate the fact that my know
eat a chode [ __ ] not scared nobody
I'm the bravest of all my friends that's
why I came out here in the middle of
woods where no one can bother me and I
can be alone with my thoughts and you
all can suck dick and choads what's this
another candle hell yeah
give me after Trent yeah just like that
okay oh so I get second oh that way I
don't waste a match okay so not again oh
god why did they feed me shrooms before
I came up here can I do this apparently
I cannot hmm well I guess I just follow
the glowing lights and then meet up all
the landmarks and then get all the demon
children to know my name and follow me
back home and need my whole family and
then destroy my dog not kill it just
destroy it that's a bad sound isn't it
hello boss on my dreams Oh God Oh God I
can do that too I can scream to listen
for her crying when she's near oh I
shouldn't have listened for her
screaming in my face is that what I was
huh I I did that all wrong I went about
this exactly the wrong way
well surely old me huh time for me to
get my silliness out of me oh well
alright let's do this [ __ ] come on
you'll sass me I've told you all to
screw yourselves ghost children that ye
may be but I am probably a proud middle
schooler who knows algebra and [ __ ] hi I
know three different geometric shapes
I'm as smart as can be top of my class
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere with a
population of two me and like my mother
brother Oh God
anyway let's just carry on here that
being too stupid the course I can't be
too stupid compared to my mother brother
no one's as stupid as her him the man
it's confusing situation when when dad's
sister comes by and meets cousin grandma
boy family reunion sure are a hootenanny
when the three of us get together oh boy
anyway what was that time not again
shut up why do you keep bringing me here
this is where it died last time we're
gonna transfer that light like a boss
man can't wait to get home and pet my
mop
okay okay okay okay okay my pet goldfish
hamster
it's really weird breeding experiment
that goes on in the middle of Kansas in
case you guys didn't know which is where
we are Oh God yeah it's me
it's skunk dog come here skunky come on
come back to me boy oh boy man there's a
lot of candles strewn about here which I
guess is good
I probably shouldn't pick all of them up
because they got a long way to go before
I get to the end of the night and see my
see my mother brother I'm a father
sister and my cousin my grandma cousin
oh oh grandma / cousin ha ha Missy where
is she oh god I shouldn't have been
sprinting that was exactly the opposite
of what I should have been doing I'm
gonna die probably
Graner seem to be alive for another
woman
oh sweet breath of life and for my lungs
make me pine for the yonder years of
when I was a child out on the farms of
Kansas with my friends who hate me for
some reason prolly cuz I'm annoying and
inbred well I heard that
oh I heard that Oh goddamn and I need to
find another candle [ __ ] I guess I was
bit destined to happen if I was just
gonna be rationing them I don't need to
ration them I just need to get from A to
B you say to be is all I need to do and
I'll trick damn it oh boy [ __ ] you that
was a [ __ ]
that was an ass blasting [ __ ] goddamn
it
where's the goddamn thing I had a
million of them oh there they are
they're all staggered over in one spot
oh no ow my fingers oh I wouldn't want
to get a little burnt no yep do that
why'd you put it back down man you
aren't too educated is that good or bad
oh that one's burning oh that's probably
bad knowing my repertoire I've sounds
that I've heard over the years of
playing horror games I'm pretty sure
that listen the bad category oh boy is
that a blood stain or just someone
chewing on the bark to clean their teeth
let me transfer the flame over here
anybody gonna pop out at me Oh mother
brother oh how I've missed the
anybody anybody
oh god no okay I thought that was
something I should probably stop
assuming that everything is something
there's no like time or anything I guess
I'm too poor 404 to watch well god
that's the beginning of the game so if I
just keep wandering around in the
pathway following the blinking lights
that probably lead me to my doom lure me
into it
ah [ __ ] you ah suck ass this is bags of
sock and ass together mixed in one it's
in a giant bag of suck ass you're not
supposed to get the two entwined it just
creates problems for everybody ball oh
okay handle up here I'm gonna grab that
yeah imma grab that thank you lads yet
I'm gonna light it now I'm a light now
I'm a lighter now I'm a lining now yeah
is it my fear levels are down no don't
be breathing in my ear like that I don't
much appreciate it
I don't much appreciate anything that's
going on here oh I wish my friends would
come rescue me
ha ha ha ha hee hee oh man when I get
back to them I'm sure I'm gonna get my
girlfriend assassin if I have a
girlfriend I don't know exactly what
character I'm playing right loner
I mean his friends didn't pretend of him
on a mountaintop I can't imagine that
he's well-loved oh well time to pull
by my bootstraps and breathe through it
another hour I gotta be kidding why
would you do that to me
why would you play in the trees it's
unsafe to be playing as a person who
started climbing a lot I kind of want to
climb some trees to be perfectly honest
now god I shouldn't go under the bridge
oh it's a bassinet oh that's full blood
I should get away from that that's
probably good thing mmm only someone's
out here having a good time taking care
of babies I guess that's a good time in
the middle of the woods
caring for babies underneath a bridge is
good time in mark Blair's book give give
give please please thank you
if I were to give any actual commentary
on the game which is probably what I
should be doing and not just running
around in fear and talking about my
balls all the brother father sister
cousin grandma then I would say that
this game actually looks good in plays
nope not going down there that's where
the good time is taking care of babies
at the bottom of the well haha boy I
remember how much time I was doing that
when I was a kid
mother brother and I would go out to
well just play for hours and hours we
were on her way back home when we
totally heard something totally like
someone asleep snoring like a mother
trucker I sure did nail the ever the
ethnicity of this scenario I sure got
the local people spot on local campers
report sound of someone sleeping really
riles up the town how dare someone be
sleeping they were snoring so loud it
was like a mother trucker what's a
mother trucker oh you know when a mother
and a brother and a truck get together
and love each other very much
they just make the truck baby and care
for it at the bottom of a well
okay suggest subject was still alive in
present in would at this damn interview
logged areum at five entered in evidence
okay so thank you everybody so much for
watching and thank you for putting up
with my borderline insanity and I will
continue playing this game if you guys
would like it's got plenty of scares and
the boya heaping helping us stupid so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
it's shower shut up no time free can't
even break up and out of my way